attempts to stem our development have
always been taken
and there are attempts to do this now on
a much larger scale of course and and
that's obvious but i'm confident that we
will overcome these difficulties and
will gain more competences more ability
to feel independent and self-sufficient
ultimately this will only be useful
just like in the previous years i will
of course update you about the situation
on ukraine and first of all on on the
course of negotiations that were that
are being conducted on a daily basis
there are some positive shifts as
i was told by our negotiators on our
side
i will let you know all the details in a
moment
our moscow correspondent diana magnay
joins me now diana suggestions today
that moscow may bring in fighters from
the middle east
that's right uh president putin held a
meeting of his security council earlier
this morning and discussed bringing in
what he called um volunteers from the
middle east to
uh assist in the liberation which is the
way russia puts it of the people of
donbass and his defence minister sergey
shoigu said that there were already 16
000 of these volunteers
in syria and the middle east who had
suggested that they would want to come
and engage in the
fight or special military operation as
as russia likes to call it um and we
have seen some videos supposedly aired
from russia's ministry of defense of
people who are keen to join dmitry
peskov the kremlin spokesman was asked
in his daily call uh what exactly that
meant that uh russia had to be sure that
there weren't any radicals amongst them
um and he said there is a very big
difference between those who fought
radicals and those who are radicals and
it would clearly be those who fought
them